[Musica]
ma non ho amici miei come sempre prima
le signore dobbiamo raggiungere il tetto
per sopravvivere e siam e mezza di
zombie ma chi vuole for dead si aspetta
aspettano questo dobbiamo fare come ci
arriviamo noi abbiamo armi chiamarmi a
sì no sì in cielo ma che brutti che sono
così la prima volta che li vedo io non
ti stringerei la mano a questo qua da
quella neanche io aspetto che c'eravamo
tra gli aqua aiuto dobbiamo prendere
migliori d'italia sino presa un po
migliore per chiamare mio dio ragazzi
aiutati sono no vabbè ma troppa gente da
parte facile della mappa cioè pensate
qua difficile come ma scusami sono
caduto giù ma come ha poi anche
rianimare la gente viola ma perché
perché sono una persona capace e sono
passato ci sono seri se la vedi quella
di monica riva aiuto e vieni qua ti
copro ce l'abbiamo fatta dai anti
lamentale non c'è una pausa però prendi
colori bisogno di riposarmi stato non
c'è i colpi per la mia arma orribile
aiuta per i propri come ce la trama su
pompa
ma che fosse un complemento vedete voi
ragazzi ho ritirato ieri abbiamo
l'impegno dell'aprile tutta la vo qui ci
risparmiamo dopo di attenzione ed io
volevamo tre teste pende ok per un
cecchino quasi un cecchino mi interessa
se prendo io non so quanto fosse ragazzi
specie altra pista c'era mai stata mia
corribile date prende roba qua da
granata dance puoi far danzare gli
zombie mamma ma sta peggiorando un sacco
sbaglio non tanto perché sono le lancia
da loro io qua qua c'è un palco show
mini parkour questo no non è un palco e
non è opportuno e cadenazzo mi faceva la
regione forse era un po ricorda vera
falcone cielo zombie dietro occhio se
davvero dovremo fare per mamma mia vabbè
però prima saltarne queste cose ce l'ho
fatta ecco io vorrei un attimino di
pausa e verrà osservata una collera
grossissimo ai profitti colpi per il mio
mg coso io né un fortino panchina ma ok
in in intenti e tieni che viene ben chi
ride
ok che grazie grazie grazie perfetto ma
no ma no non spendo ricaricare c21
storia ricarica star ma mi ha fatto
anche male
mamma mia sono quindici di vita
ok perfetto oggi un petto il corpo
perfetto una mazza occhio che sta
spaccando qualcuno non so dove ricevera
lunedi pende raga io ne ho trovato una
fonduta tirare perché abbiamo in termini
troppo di uno show da qui sotto vamonos
corribile che anzi ha veramente mi rendo
conto nella la mappa è molto bella molto
bella monaca vacca oggi la doppietta è
un casino
sì mi sa che fanno il tentativo vero che
succede che si fa anche abbastanza
schifo sia esploso prendi questi colpi
thank you
docente ma fuori sì c'è anche la tenda
120 in casinò sono e vende le prendo
mentre sono dentro il camion venute le
scorrerie resistere furgone sopra ma noi
non ci sono più allora dobbiamo da mamma
mia ragazzi ansia in mezzo a dei muri
giusta la destra dobbiamo andare o in
mezzo a quindi murio dobbiamo superare
la barricata listino di due allora
aspettate che kg questi con una dinamica
è così non sprechiamo né che i colpi e
poi parliamo ok
vai adesso erano i muri giusto ai è
scoppiata nonna mio dio
venite andiamo andiamo a cercare un
sacco di loop dicono invece che non
servono a niente non puoi morire quindi
quindi non ho capito è tanto la minicar
di alcan torretta la torretta dovete
conoscere la gente c'era infatti gente
rimpiazzarlo acqua per forza perché se
no sei riuscito complici copy ci dovete
ammazzare i peli dietro con troppi
errori
mamma mia ragazzi quanti sono l'ho fatto
l'ho fatto io sono qua fuori gara
mamma mia ragazzi bile no non ho capito
vi do una mano vita e una vita orribile
visto nessun rischio andamento e ho
finito per i conti va bene l'ho salvata
ma se stessimo ancora la torretta e
promesso lontano bene ho chiuso dice ok
appena esploso una colonna e poi far
investivamo di strani me no
il 5 altro po esclusivo che io sorprende
colpi notiamo anche io ho preso un po di
volpi che tanto il fucile a pompa mi
serve un deteriora ancora caversela le
mie mese cioè un labirinto lega cavalca
occhio ma la viola vinto ce l'ha vinto
da fare mio dio
si spera che lo prendo io che ne ha già
uno jean altre colonne a mio zio pietro
lo trovo un missile per rocket launcher
ok ok ed evolvere non avrà in continuo a
muoverci che dobbiamo muoverci se stiamo
fermi da fine memoria ea praga occhio
che si parlano di spanò davanti alla
faccia si siano trovate plancia e un 5
di rocket lancio arrivando non avere i
compagni ore l'ex ala liga prof
ok per madonna mister andrea alla fine
uno stereo non so cosa servono ma è il
momento perfetto no no no no no no si
fermano aiuto
avevo finiti con sbucciato su rocchi e
torino sono sparati sui piedi
ok belgio allora quando casinò mio di
operai o ci mettiamo una vita di nuovo
quindi occhio stiamo insieme libero
mentre chi vedi qui in val cui il
parkour non è per cui no credo sia una
zona chiusa vi processo anche se spero x
cat volevo portare una volta che lo si
può dare alle mie tecniche a nicolas sta
andando bene sta andando bene ignoriamo
i colpi perché mandare a di colpire me
colpi di qui proviamo qui la via vale
l'altra perché non c'è un arco però
esclusive sono lo può prendere prendo io
non ti prendi dovrei saperlo usare bene
siamo così ma mai occhio tra libertà
dove puoi usare pd quindi non è così
buono si è un po più aperte te lo puoi
gestire quasi per intero
adesso fa schifo per le assenze
la mia ragazza difficile ragazzi sono un
sacco di zombie ma c'è un coro da
distruggere inutile l'intervento se
stiamo trovando tutti i micro nidi
famiglia esista è un dramma questa nuova
casa la vittoria di bill e la gara di
sci catrame sembra di aver visto tutto
ma forse colato ma c'è qualcosa se non
altro lato del parkour
eccola l'ho trovata i ragazzi stanno
fatto il giovanissimo chef e tumino
l'altro lato riuscita o ok dai e per e
lamenta che pazzini va allora stiamo
salendo secondo me siamo alla fine
preferiamo l'obiettivo era arrivare in
un telo arrivare al tetto e noi ci siamo
nel tè speriamo perché dal basso la
battaglia finale come le final battle
plate sarebbe difficile ok ok facciamo
attenzione
mamma mia ragazza ebbe proprio indice
tornare qua
ok allora non arrivano poi centinario
sbaglio no abbiamo non ci credo che
maledetti ammesso dei blocchi visibili
ma vediamo sotto di noi però sottolineo
nobili se ci vengono addosso di poter
stilare dai dai al glorioso proprio loro
che ci tengono alla gloria e la fama da
gama pronunciamenti di struzzi ha
fruttato al centro dobbiamo a dominarlo
perfetto di tutto di imprenditori
carissimi celato facendo sto facendo sto
facendo sto facendo ma cento facendo sta
facendo occhio di tom bgg neonata è
teoricamente era più facile di quello
che pensassi che io maria però chiaro
non ci ha fatto prendere va bene
infinito aveva finito la casa di 118
credo che il finale era un po brutto si
poteva essere meglio in finale a
mancherà [ __ ] però avete visto che del
successo a me stendendo solerio
esplodere una bomba tipo ottimo alla
fine era un plot twist heads up ragazzi
questa era la mappa è stata molto carina
mi è piaciuta parecchio ragazzi va beh
ringrazio il placement console per
avermi salvato la vita a molteplici
volte oggi grazie
e stato molto bello lavorare di squadra
in questo video che i ragazzi proviene
semplice
ringrazio sempre per avere partecipato è
stato il codice creatore trovati in
svizzera se la vuoi cities chiede
ovviamente anche il canale di sterpete e
noi ci vogliamo bene
[Musica]